following totals atomic annihilation the
rebuilding of this great nation of ours
may fall to you that's why we at vortex
have prepared these educational
materials for you to better understand
the seven defining attributes that make
you special in this chapter we focus on
perception it is the unfortunate truth
that when you go above ground you will
be faced with many post-nuclear
nuisances these frightening menaces will
come in all different shapes and sizes
and pose an immediate threat to your
survival you must learn to deal with
these dangers but may find this
challenging at first that's why we've
provided you with the vault-tec
assistant targeting system so you can
scan the threat and pinpoint areas of
weakness and the higher your perception
the more accurate you will be why you'll
put Davy Crockett to shame there may be
times when you must engage in
questionable activities your perception
can help keep you safe during these
morally ambiguous moments practice your
pilfering on youths the elderly or the
incapacitated
as you continue to purloin your way to
success try more challenging targets and
more skillful techniques for greater
returns don't get too cocky there sport
always look to sharpen your five senses
for perception doesn't stop there keenly
assessing the unfriendly locals and
terrain handling sensitive munitions
with blend building a long distance
relationship regularly study your
vault-tec provided materials to prepare
for survival and to answer the question
do you know what makes you special
Oh